well Oh feels like scraping the bottom
of the barrel so a little while ago I
did my list for 10 best villains of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and well I got
to redress the balance I gotta talk
about the 10 worst so ok
reminder for this list unlike most of my
MCU list which I restrict to the movies
I am opening this one up to include
characters from the TV shows you know
the ABC shows the Netflix shows all of
that so yeah let's get through this
let's start out with number 10 [ __ ]
Ilyas from Doctor Strange he's gonna
kick off the first is what I'm gonna be
a bit of a trend with a fair number of
these which is just that he's generic
he's boring and in Kelley is this case
it's made a little bit extra worse
because well he's presented as the
primary villain of this thing but we
know he's effectively a henchman to a
bigger baddie so I mean again he is
nominally the villain of this film and
the reason he's not any in any worse
place than this and he's occupying you
know the the bottom you know the the low
end the least worst and of the list is
because Mads Mikkelsen brings a little
extra something to it he does he
elevates the material a little there's
only so far could be elevated because
it's not great material number 9 Yellow
Jacket another case of a bland boring
villain but worse than someone like [ __ ]
Ilyas because a recycled bland boring
villain because oh look it's Obadiah
Stane for ant-man so for the record
Obadiah Stane is not on this list
because at the very least Jeff Bridges
has a commanding presence which helps
this this guy Darren cross this
character he's just I you know there's
kind of a hand wavy explanation as to
why he acts the way he does the like
he's been around this kind of tech too
long or actually that may even have been
a meta explanation I heard for why he
acts so mustache twirling Li villainous
but it doesn't matter if you can justify
it or not it's stupid like the point at
which I completely stop taking him
seriously as a villain is the instant he
shrunk down that guy in the in the
bathroom but I'm no I just can't with
this guy
number eight Diamondback the villain
replacements from the first season of
Luke Cage after giving us was about six
episodes of getting us invested in
Marshall Holly as cottonmouth who was so
good and watching him unravel was
becoming a really fascinating thing and
then he's dead and this dude just shows
up out of nowhere going I'm your brother
wait who are you and he doesn't rank any
you know any worse than this simply
because it did the conflict of this dog
I did bring some decent stuff out of
Luke so he's kind of functional but
barely and it was you know we threw away
such a good villain to bring this guy in
and it's a ship that doesn't work worth
a dang at all the suit that he's in and
the final fight looks stupid like that I
think the only moment I liked this guy
was when he first showed up quoting you
know the what is it the Warriors can you
dig it I'm like oh cool and then after
that as I oh this guy is just a whole
lot of nothing number seven Ronan the
accuser back to generic world and yeah
he's just bland uninteresting his
motivations are under explained he
I'd like [ __ ] ileus who came I was gonna
say before him as far as the porter
releases it was after he is not actually
the big baddie of the overall narrative
going on where again we're dealing with
a henchman for our villain for this he's
not particularly threatening he's just
there he's just he's practically just a
punching bag he is something for the
heroes to occasionally throw themself
against and bounce off of until
eventually they all throw themselves at
him at the same time and knock him down
and he stays down I mean that's that's
what he feels like they could they could
have replaced him oh they totally could
have replaced him with one of those sort
of impact dummies you know the one
that's just the upper torso that you
can't get his like move when it comes
back that's him that might as well have
been Ronan number six the one that I'm
probably gonna get the hardest pushback
on red skull I don't get why anyone
likes him and his appearance in in the
First Avenger I don't I don't again
generic as hell so over the top and
Johann Schmidt the Red Skull is a great
character in the comics he's not made as
wonderfully hateable
here as he is in the comics I think it's
completely unnecessary the way that they
like immediately break Hydra from the
Nazis so there's like Oh see they're
even worse than not just have them be a
friggin Nazi don't have him using the
Nazis he's a Nazi
have him be a Nazi have him stay with
the Nazis not like I must break from the
Nazis and do this up know have him all
in on their philosophy that's part of
what's so scary about him or it should
be and the performances of the book
credit where credit's due he looks
phenomenal
but he's so he's completely and utterly
generic he is it is just bog-standard
and he's not threatening he's not it
never feels like he's winning ever him
and Hydra as an organization in that
at least hydras not on this list because
they've been used better in other
scenarios but hydrants they appear in
here might as well being cobra and and
skull and the red skull was practically
cobra commander as far as I'm concerned
and no it is his cameo appearance in and
Infinity Ward does not up him that was a
very cool Easter Egg but it doesn't do
anything with him as a character it's
it's just a cool Easter Egg that doesn't
elevate him
number five hive boy didn't even realize
that rhymed
so from agents of shield season three
and this one is on here largely out of
spite because if you watched my best
villains of the MCU list you would have
seen the ward on there and Ward was an
awesome villain he was a terrific wild
card he knew how to get under the skin
of the agents and he had a you know a
great deep history with them how bad he
was was awesome he always seemed to have
his own agenda so he wasn't just like we
must stop him and his plan he's like
he's here screwing everything up we
don't know why and he was threatening
and he was vicious and they killed him
and had this totally generic world
ending thing walk around with his face
boring dull and add even a higher level
than Diamondback replacing cottonmouth a
waste of an awesome villain sacrifice on
the altar of generic boring garbage
number four
Killian from Iron Man 3 now I actually
think Iron Man 3 gets over hated in some
circles especially honestly I think it
gets legitimately overrated in terms of
the Mandarin twist now I say that
specific to Ben Kingsley's part in that
had revealing that this omnipotent this
you know almighty terrorist was a decoy
that's a really cool twist on
fortunately the villain that we get
instead guy Pierce's Killian is again
generic unintimidating the latest
iteration of Obadiah Stane and he's he's
not scary it's not cathartic when he
gets beaten it
he doesn't feel threatening he just
feels like an annoyance he feels like an
irritation and as much as I will defend
that twist with the Mandarin if you were
going to remove what appeared to be such
a cool and awesome villain you needed to
have something of equal or greater
stature to step in and fill the void
after him and Killian absolutely does
not do that at all number three the last
of the characters on here for being
boring and bland because yes he is so
bland he cracks the top three for worst
Malekith from Thor the dark world the
character that it seems like no one else
can ever remember his name that's how
bland he was what a waste of a great
actor Christopher Eccleston is an
awesome actor and he's doing the best
that he can you know - and he brings us
a certain amount of presence to this
part but it is utterly generic bland
unmemorable uninteresting he has almost
no personality to speak of his
motivation is bog-standard
what he is doing is your standard
universe ending you say and again it's
it's poorly explained it's poorly
motivated you when you properly motivate
a villain who wants to more or less end
a good chunk of the universe
you get Thanos when you don't explained
it worth of dang at all and then he has
no personality on top of it you get
Malekith and Malekith is just a black
hole of a character nothing interesting
can escape his Pole now these last two
are interlinked
and Inter woven with each other but I am
so gonna deal with them separately so
first of all number two Elektra and yes
I am considering Elektra a straight-up
villain because of her use in the
defenders and I'm placing her on here
largely for her use in that although her
appearance in daredevil season dude is
factoring in slightly not heavily
because she wasn't really the villain in
that but it's still factoring in and so
far as I feel like she is a character
with almost no agency almost no Drive
everything about her is defined by other
people
she shows up because of her connection
with Matthew she ropes him into
everything that's going on because she
is following stick she comes back
brought back to life by the hand and she
is on their agenda she takes over the
hand and that is supposed to be like a
big deal like it's supposed to be
intimidating and scary
except it's not because I don't know
where as a character I don't understand
what she would do with the hand because
I have no clue who she is I can't tell
you anything about her as a character
aside from the fact that she's a bit
tasty in a fight and she really likes
Matt that's it for as many episodes of
television as she appeared in the fact
that that it seems to be the entirety of
her characterization and they cast an
actress who can do the physicality okay
but does not have the genuine presence
needed to make to make this come across
it to sell that Matt wouldn't be
obsessed with her the way that he is it
just falls so flat and is so boring and
is so dull and was so aggravating when
she when it was supposed to be like a
big deal that she kind of turned into
the main villain and in the defenders go
what oh so annoying and then closely
tied to that number one worst villain in
the MCU collectively the hey
how do you make a ninja death cult
criminal syndicate uninteresting it's
like a magic trick the hand were scary
for the entirety of the fight were one
of them fought Matt in the first season
of daredevil every other appearance
since then the more we learned about
them the stupid are they got in terms of
the way the organization works in terms
of how they function in the stories in
terms of the individuals that we know
who operate in the hand in terms of the
supposed overall goals why is any of
this scary like there's all this
emphasis put on if they ever get back to
: if they you want to finish that
sentence you want to say what would
happen if they got back to come on they
never say you never say we don't know
the value of kun LUN but then
threatening it is apparently they all we
must kill all these people and they also
act so stupidly in the defenders oh my
god so they have their whole immortality
juice stuff that they use to stay alive
but they're currently out of it they're
harvesting the stuff to get more but
right now they're vulnerable
they could die they still have minions
left do they have those minions mining
the stuff they need and when the heroes
show up they themselves the leaders of
the hand at their most vulnerable meet
them in the parking lot to fight them
hand on hand
watch how stupid are you that you would
do that well you're at your most
vulnerable and again their only goal
seems to be just to live forever to get
back to :
and it's never explained why this is
actually a bad freaking thing I'm not
saying that they're good people they run
criminal organizations but so what Lee
you can't sell them as this big
overarching world-threatening thing and
they've also got all that crap of the
black sky whatever the heck the black
sky was anybody no hands up there are no
hands up cuz nobody else would
that once we have this kid that sticks
that had to die and then electricals
maggot cheese the black tram what is the
black sky all electric does when she
comes back is be kind of okay in a fight
but get her butt kicked repeatedly by
the heroes and then then as I mentioned
in the last entry take over the hand and
to do ninja to do what do you want to do
nothing to be nothing cuz my hand is
just nothing and yet eight up so many
hours of multiple shows why god I hate
them so much and I really hope they
never ever ever come back after the
defenders please even Madame Gao I liked
her as an individual character but even
her she's been tainted no more for the
love of God and that's why I listed the
ten worst villains Hey
let it loose a little there I think okay
who do you think were the worst villains
in the MCU if you want to restrict it
the movies you want to open after the
shows whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do you know the stuff like and subscribe
and support me on Twitter it's kind
Twitter I don't need your support on
Twitter follow me on Twitter support me
on patreon that's kind of the big one
god I think I burned out by brain on
that last stretch of the rant in any
case links for all the stuff I mentioned
and more stuff besides it's gotta be
down in the description so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]